[Music]
it sounds really strange to speak of the
upsides of being ill surely there are
only downsides
but rather than assuming as we normally
do that our mental illnesses are just a
problem for us we can dare to ask in a
spirit of open-minded exploration what
are my illnesses doing for me whatever
their costs what are their secret
upsides what are their unexpected
benefits why might i be covertly siding
with them against the possibility of
health
we often develop psychological illnesses
because the alternative to them is in
some way worse the illness protects us
at huge and tragic cost from a
confrontation with something that
threatens to be yet more painful and
psychologically difficult the truth
about what has happened to us what we
need to do next and the true nature of
certain people we are close to
think of the person who repeatedly fails
her exams despite being very intelligent
and driven what could possibly be the
benefit of an illness as awful as
self-sabotage but if we examine this
person's life we might find the presence
of a hugely competitive and jealous
mother who could be extremely displeased
by her daughter's success and might
respond by cutting off her love and
becoming highly aggressive the daughter
hence chooses the illness of
self-sabotage over the yet more awful
realization that her mother was damaged
and damaging and never loved her
properly it can feel better to be ill
than realize one was always unloved
behind a great many psychological
illnesses we uncover benefits if we can
put it that way
failing can be a protection against
being envied
worrying about our appearance can
distract us from the fact we were made
to feel horribly unworthy as a child
being manically busy can block out
uncomfortable news of our true sexual
desires being paranoid can prevent us
from acknowledging who we are really
annoyed with an addiction can keep us
ignorant of our early abuse
in certain circumstances getting ill is
to our unconscious minds at least the
easier route it might not be in any way
nice or simple to be always impotent or
worried or a failure or paranoid but
these options might nevertheless be
better than realizing that one has an
altogether different sexuality or was
furious with a supposedly beloved parent
or is jealous of a sibling or should be
changing jobs or leaving a partner
behind a great many psychological
illnesses is a highly distressing truth
we've exchanged for a neurotic symptom
once we realize the overall mechanism we
should whenever an illness comes into
view repeat the naive inquiry what is
the peculiar and particular advantage of
this illness for me what does it prevent
me from knowing about myself
what would i need to do if i wasn't ill
what is the upside of feeling depressed
or of blowing up a relationship or of
being impotent or friendless
we may generally complain about these
problems but if we can put it this way
what purpose are they serving for us
we can then dare to think that there is
something worse something truly
difficult to swallow that we are
protecting ourselves from via being
unwell the way to overcome a mental
affliction is to cease to look at it
merely as an explanationless nuisance
it may be a shield protecting us from
what we deep down suspect mistakenly
would hurt us more
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you